okay so in this video we're gonna go
over what is called passive transport
now here's a little example that I'm
sure you've all have noticed here we
have a beaker of water and let's say we
add one to three drops a red food
coloring notice how the red food color
and give it time give it a few minutes
will eventually spread over the entire
container and you don't even have to
stir up the container but eventually the
entire liquid will be red well that's a
great example of something called
diffusion which is a type of passive
transport let's go ahead and discuss
this in more detail so when we look at
the definition of passive transport it's
pretty straightforward
it's how cells move molecules without
spending any of their energy and in the
world of cells energy is a molecule
called adenosine triphosphate ATP you'll
often hear ATP kind of compared to as
money of a cell you know when you have
money you want to spend your money
carefully when cells have ATP energy
they wanna you spend their ATP yeah
carefully so that I want to be careless
with how they spend their ATP and so
cells would love to move molecules
around without having to spend any of
their ATP energy well this is what we
call passive transport
it's how cells move molecules without
spending ATP in my animation here by the
way I have a kayaker ask yourself does
this kayaker need to spend any of his
energy in order to move you can see that
the black lines are showing the current
of this river I hope you know the answer
is no the kayaker kayaker can just sit
there and let the current of the river
take the kayaker downstream that kayaker
didn't need to spend any energy and so
when we look at passive transport again
it's we're going to show you it's how
molecules move from a high concentration
to a low concentration and this process
requires no energy by high concentration
we mean where the molecules are most
abundant or
plentiful in this picture right here you
can see the yellow dots are representing
molecules and their most abundant in the
lower left-hand corner but as we go
through this animation the yellow dots
are beginning to spread out and now
they're fully spread out over the entire
size of this container this is what we
mean by molecules moving from a high to
a low concentration we kind of say it's
like they move down their concentration
gradient so they start high and they
move down to a low concentration
examples of passive transport and that's
what the rest of this video is going to
discuss our diffusion osmosis and
facilitated diffusion so let's go into
diffusion first okay when we look at
diffusion again we have a simple
definition here it's the movement of
molecules from an area of high to low
concentration and as we said a moment
ago it's an example of passive
transports and no energy is required the
movement of these molecules is going to
continue until there's an equilibrium a
state of balance and so in in my picture
up here we can see that the yellow dots
are all clumped and concentrated at the
left of the picture and over on the
right side of the picture there's a
couple yellow dots but you can see that
they're less concentrated so molecules
are gonna spread out and move until
there's a balance this is called
diffusion and diffusion is really how
molecules move into and out of most
cells and it's something we're going to
discuss in a little more detail so right
here we have a cell surrounded by oxygen
and my question in Oh too is oxygen my
question in the middle is well oxygen
mostly enter or will oxygen mostly exit
the cell will find the high
concentration I hope you can see the
high concentrations on the outside of
the cell and so by diffusion moving from
high to low if it's gonna move oxygen is
gonna move from the outside to the
inside notice how a couple oxygens
exited the cell but the vast majority
entered the cell and now there's a nice
balance we have that state called
equilibrium where is a neat little annum
animation here about our about us
breathing here we have a lady doing yoga
and she's inhaling a big breath of o2
which is oxygen let's follow that oxygen
into her lungs when we zoom on into her
lungs we can see that the oxygen the o2
has spread to all those branches inside
of her lungs so when we zoom out in even
more to her lungs we know that you might
know that you are the the tips of your
lungs those branches the tips of the
branches inside of your lungs have these
little air sacs in them called the
alveoli and so in this animation here
here's an air sac that's just filled up
with o2 and my question is where is the
high oxygen concentration and where is
the low oxygen concentration I hope you
can see the high oxygen concentration is
in the alveoli and the low oxygen
concentration is in the bloodstream so
due to diffusion oxygen will simply move
from a high to a low concentration so
now that there's oxygen in the
bloodstream how does that oxygen get
spread around the body our heart our
heart will now because our heart is
constantly pumping and beating our heart
will pump our blood which is now full of
oxygen around this woman's body so there
goes the oxygen it's being pumped around
her body and when we follow that oxygen
when we follow the oxygen here's the
oxygen that she just inhaled and if I
were to ask you okay you know find cell
X at the bottom of the picture cell X is
a cell just like every other cell it
needs oxygen
notice how cell X is not in direct
contact with the blood flow with the
bloodstream so how the heck does cell X
get up well the simple answer for how
cell X gets
oxygen is if we remember what diffusion
is diffusion is the movement of
molecules from a high to a low
concentration ask yourself where is the
high oxygen concentration and ask
yourself where is the low oxygen well
the high oxygen concentration is in the
blood the low oxygen is in cell X and
all the other cells and so simply by
diffusion molecules are going to move
from a high concentration the blood flow
to a low concentration the cells so cell
X and all the other cells get their
oxygen through the process of diffusion
well this reverse process is true with
carbon dioxide over time your cells
create carbon dioxide as a waste gas it
builds up in cells and too much is fatal
it needs to be removed
so as our cells work to remove carbon
dioxide ask yourself where is the high
carbon dioxide concentration and where
is the low carbon dioxide concentration
I hope you see the high carbon dioxide
concentration is in the cells the low
carbon dioxide concentration is in the
blood so carbon dioxide is simply going
to diffuse from the cells into the blood
and once the carbon dioxide is in the
blood don't forget your heart is still
pumping and so your heart is still
pumping blood and now in this case our
blood is full of carbon dioxide this
carbon dioxide rich blood is going to go
back to the lungs so let's go back to
the lungs and and follow this process to
the end when we come back to the lungs
again there's our air sac called the
alveoli and here we have our heart
pumping carbon dioxide back to the lungs
and my question is where is the high
carbon dioxide concentration I hope you
see it's in the blood and so carbon
dioxide is simply going to diffuse from
a high concentration in the blood to a
low concentration in the alveoli and now
that co2 is back in the lungs
we simply begin the exhale
so the woman begins to exhale you also
have a a muscle underneath your ribs are
underneath your lungs and between your
ribs called your diaphragm that helps to
push out some of the carbon dioxide and
so I mentioned a moment ago the
diaphragm is a muscle that helps push
out some of the co2 from the lungs and
now we're back to where we started this
woman who was doing yoga and is
breathing heavily she just exhaled a
bunch of carbon dioxide and the process
will simply repeat with every breath
well let's turn directions and focus on
another type of passive transport called
as Moses as Moses is the same thing as
diffusion don't mix the two up they
really are the same thing the big
difference is that osmosis implies water
as Moses implies the diffusion of water
from a high concentration to a low
concentration and so in this animation
here pretend that we have a container of
distilled water and if you're not sure
what distilled water is it's a hundred
percent pure water there are no solutes
in it it's as pure as water can
reasonably be it's also something
doesn't exist naturally on earth there's
no rivers of distilled water
there's no lakes it doesn't rain
distilled water distilled water is
created basically in a chemistry lab
well so here we have a cell placed in a
container of 100% pure water there's
nothing in this water other than water
and this is an example of what is called
a hypotonic environment when cells are
placed in a hypotonic environment ask
yourself where is the high water
concentration I hope you see it's on the
outside of the cell and so the high
water concentration is on the outside of
the cell and osmosis is moving a water
from high to low high to low
concentration so in this case water will
move from the water into the cell and
the cell will swell up and get bigger
and bigger and bigger to the point where
it very well could even burst yeah well
I'm not necessarily gonna burst but if
it swells too much it very well might
well and another the kind of the
opposite of this is something is
saltwater saltwater is high in solutes
namely salt and so in this picture here
we have a cell filled with water but
notice this is the water inside of the
cell is fairly pure but the water
outside of the cell has a bunch of s is
the s is stand for salt remember this is
saltwater so when you look at this
picture this is an example of what is
called a hypertonic environment and in
this case the high water concentration
is in the cell there might be more
individual water molecules outside of
the cell if you were to actually count
them up but the fact that the water on
the outside is mixed with salt makes the
water on the outside less pure and so
water moves from a high concentration to
a low so water will move from the cell
to the outside the cell very well might
even shrivel and become dehydrated so
these are examples of this is an example
of a hypertonic environment and how
cells react to them so there's a quick
little lab activity let's say here is a
potato slice that's placed in the inside
of a dish a container of salt water and
here's another potato slice in a
container of distilled water
well after 30 minutes let's say you were
to weigh them before and after and the
potato slice slice lost weight in the
salt water container but in the
distilled water after 30 minutes the
potato slice got heavier it gained
weight so if we were in class I would
have you pause and try to answer these
questions with your neighbors so if
you're watching this video pause the
video I'm gonna go over these answers in
three two one so let's look at the salt
water potato first where is the high
concentration experiment well well so
where is the high concentration in the
salt water experiment well if you know
that it lost weight that's because it
lost water and so in my animation you
can see that water again moves from a
high concentration to a
concentration so water must be exiting
this potato slice and so once you I had
once you identify this and examine this
animation it's pretty straightforward
there's a high water concentration in
the potato there's a low water
concentration in the solution outside in
the water outside the potato died when
we look at the other side we can see
that the distilled potato the water put
in distilled water got heavier the
reason it got heavier is because it
absorbed water and so if we know that
water went into it that means the high
concentration was on the outside of the
potato and the low concentration was on
the inside and water moves from high to
low and that's why it got heavier and so
that answers question one two and three
well here's a couple more to ponder
again if we were in a class I'll give
you some time to work on this with your
neighbor
pause via I paused the video I'm gonna
go over these answers in three two one
so why did the saltwater potato lose
weight you know try to avoid answers
like I lost weight because it got
dehydrated that's true it the potato
slice did become dehydrated but why and
so this is what we mean by you know be
thorough with your answers water
diffused out of the potato water moved
from a high concentration inside the
potato to a low concentration outside
the potato number six why did the the
distilled water potato gain weight try
to avoid answers like in a gained weight
because it absorbed the water that's
true it did absorb water but why it
absorbed water because again there was a
high concentration of water outside the
potato on low concentration inside so
water diffused into into the potato so
let's wrap up this video here
facilitated diffusion is our final type
of passive transport I want to mention
and so remember that in the animation
right now you can see that these blue
dots are representing like oxygen and
carbon dioxide and and small molecules
like this are able to pass
directly through the cell membrane and
that's what you see happening right here
now they're the topic we're looking at
right now is called facilitated
diffusion now the word facilitate simply
means to help and so what we're going to
show you that sometimes diffusion needs
a little help in facilitated diffusion
larger molecules are going to enter and
exit with the help member facilitate
means help so larger molecules are going
to enter and exit with the help of
what's called a protein channel located
within the cell membrane or the plasma
membrane watch this
glucose is just too big of a molecule to
pass directly through the cell membrane
however because of the protein channels
that are embedded throughout the cell
membrane glucose molecules can pass
through from the outside to the inside
of the cell and no energy is required
and again this is what we mean by
passive transport no ATP energy is
required for this to happen and so one
more time here comes a glucose molecule
passing through the protein channel and
so these protein channels help larger
molecules go through diffusion and
that's why it's called facilitated
diffusion so when we wrap up this video
if you're in my class pause the video
and try to answer these ten questions in
fact there's actually two more questions
after this there's a total of twelve so
here's one through ten pause the video
if you're working on them at home I'm
going to show you eleven and twelve
right now so here are the last two
questions in this practice quiz so pause
the video and try to answer 1 through 12
if you're in my biology class I'd be
happy to check your answers either
before class or after class one day so
good